what is the process of observation like
this
uh like observing the personality but
also observing in a way
that's not projecting your beliefs about
human nature or animal nature onto
chimps
which is probably really tempting
to project so your understanding of the
way the human world works
projecting that onto
the chimp world
yes i mean it's particularly difficult
with chimps because chimps are so
similar to humans in their behavior
that it's very easy
to to make those projections as you say
the process involves
making very clear definitions of of what
a behavior is
um you know aggression uh
can be defined in terms of
a forceful hit a bite and so on
um and writing down every time these
things happen
and then slowly totting up the numbers
of times that they happen uh you know
from individual a towards individuals b
c d and e
so that you build up a very concrete
picture rather than interpreting at any
point and stopping and saying well you
know they seem to be rather aggressive
uh so the
uh
the formal system is that you build up a
pattern of the relationships based on
a
description of the different types of
interactions the aggressive and the
friendly interactions
and all of these are defined in concrete
and
so that from that you extract a pattern
of relationships
and the relationships uh can be defined
as
um
you know relatively friendly relatively
uh
aggressive competitive
based on the frequency of these types of
interactions
and so one can talk in terms of
uh individuals having
a relationship which on the scores of
friendliness is
two standard deviations outside the mean
i mean
you know it's in which direction sorry
in both directions
well i mean yeah that would be obviously
the friendly ones would be the ones who
have exceptionally high rates of
spending time close to each other of
touching each other in a gentle way of
grooming each other
and by the way finding that those things
are correlated with each other
so
it's possible to define a friendship
with a capital f in a very systematic
way and and to compare that
between
uh individuals but also between
communities of chimpanzees
and between different species
so that you know we can say that in some
species individuals have friends and
others they don't at all
what about just because there's
different personalities and because
they're so fascinating what about sort
of falling in love or forming
friendships with chimps you know like
really
you know um connecting with them
as an observer what what role does that
play cause you're tracking these
individuals that are full of life and
intelligence from for
long periods of time plus as a human
especially in those days for jane she's
alone observing it it gets lonely as a
human i mean probably deeply lonely as a
human being observe these other
intelligent species
it's a very reasonable question and of
course jane in his early years i think
she's willing now to talk about the fact
that
she regrets to some extent how close she
became
and the problem is not just from the
humans the problem is from the
chimpanzees as well because
they do things that are
extremely affectionate if you like you
know um at one point
jane
uh offered a a ripe fruit
to a chimpanzee called david greybeard
david greybeard
took it and squeezed her hand
as if to say thank you and then i think
he gave it back if i remember rightly
yeah
[Laughter]
no thank you
right
oh it's as almost like thank you and uh
returning the affection by giving the
food yeah if if they didn't you know it
was a gentle squeeze you know i mean
chimpanzees could squeeze you very hard
as that occasionally has happened
some chimps are aggressive to people
um and others are friendly
and the ones that are friendly tend to
be rather sympathetic characters because
they might be
ones who are having problems in their
own society
you know so jomio in gombe used to uh
come and sit next to me quite often um
and uh he was having a hard time making
it in that society you know which i can
describe to you in terms of the number
of aggressive interactions if you want
you know but um just to be informed
about it
so
all of this is a temptation to be very
firmly resisted
and
in the community that i've been working
with in uganda for the last 30 years we
try extremely hard to impress on all of
the research students who come with us
that it is absolutely vital that you do
not fall into that temptation now you
know we heard a story of one person who
did reach out and touch one of our
chimps
it's a very very bad idea
not because the chimp is going to
do anything violent at the time
but because if they learn
that humans are as weak uh physically as
we are compared to them then they can
take advantage of it
us and that's what happened in gambi so
after jane had
done the um you know very obvious thing
when you're first engaged in this
game
of
allowing the infants to approach her and
then tickling them and playing with them
some of those infants
had the personality
of wanting to take advantage of that
knowledge later
and so you know you had an individual
frodo who was
um violent on a regular basis towards
humans when he was an adult and he was
quite dangerous i mean he could easily
have killed someone in fact he did kill
one one person he killed a baby uh that
he he he took from a mother a human baby
that he took off her hip when he met her
on the path
so it's a reminder that we're dealing
with
a species
that are rather human-like in the range
of emotions they have in the capacities
they have
and even
in the strength they have they are
in many ways stronger than humans so
it's uh
you you've got to be careful
in the full range of friendliness and
violence the capacity for these very
human things
yes i mean it's it's very obvious with
with violence as we talked about you
know that uh they will kill they will
kill not just strangers
um
they can
kill
other adults within their own group uh
they can kill babies that are strangers
they can kill babies in their own group
so you know they're
this is a long-lived individual
obviously these killings can't have very
often because otherwise they'd all be
dead
um
and
we're now finding that they can live to
50 or 60 years in the wild at relatively
low population density because they're
big animals eating a rather specialized
kind of food the ripe fruits
so it doesn't happen all the time with
friendliness
they are very strong to support each
other they very much depend on their um
their close friendships
uh which they express through
uh physical contact
and particularly through through
grooming so grooming
occurs when one individual approaches
another
i might present
for grooming a very common way of
starting
turning their back or presenting an arm
or something like that and the other
just ripples their fingers through the
hair
and that's partly just soothing
and it's partly uh looking for
parasites
but mostly it's just soothing yes and
and the point about this is it can go on
for uh
half an hour it can go on for sometimes
even an hour
so this is amazing you know a major
expression of interest in somebody else
when did your interest in this one
particular aspects of jim
come to be which is violence when did
the study of violence in chimps
become something you're deeply
interested in
well
for my phd in the early 1970s
i was in gombe with jane goodall and was
studying feeding behavior
but during that time
we were seeing and i say we because
there were
half a dozen research students
all
in her camp
we were discovering
that chimps had this capacity for for
violence
the first kill happened during that time
which was of an infant and a neighboring
group
um
and we were starting to see these uh
hunting expeditions
and this was uh the start of my interest
because it was such chilling evidence of
an extraordinary similarity between
chimps
and humans
now at that time
we didn't know very much
about how chimpanzees and humans were
related
chimps gorillas
bonobos are all
three big black hairy things that live
in the african forests and uh eat fruits
and
leaves when they can't find fruits
and walk on their knuckles and they all
look rather similar to each other so
they seem as though
those three species chimps and gorillas
and bonobos should all be each other's
closest relatives and humans are
something rather separate and so any of
them will be of interest to us
subsequently we learn
that actually that's not true and that
there's a special relationship between
humans and chimpanzees
but at the time
even without knowing that it was obvious
that there was something very odd about
chimpanzees because
jane had discovered they were making
tools
she had seen that they were hunting meat
she had seen that they were sharing the
meat among each other she had seen that
the societies were dominated politically
by males coalitions of males all of
these things of course resonate so
closely with humans
and then it turns out
that
in contrast to conventional wisdom at
the time
the chimpanzees were capable of hunting
and killing members of neighboring
groups
well
at that point
the similarities between chimps and
humans
become less a matter of
sort of you know sheer intellectual
fascination
than something that has a really deep
meaning about our understanding of
ourselves
i mean until then
you can cheerfully think of humans as a
species apart from the rest of nature
because we are so peculiar but when it
turns out that
as it turns out one of our two closest
relatives
has got these features that we share
and that one of the features is
something that is the most horrendous
as well as fascinating
aspect of human behavior then you know
how can you resist just
you know trying to find out what's going
on
you